you know what we have going on very much
so in America right now is that Donald
Trump just this week says we're gonna
close the borders to all Muslims well
now he throws red meat to the right he
gets he probably does more good work for
Isis recruiting that he could possibly
do but unfortunately he's been
strengthened by by a week left you talk
a lot about that actually about how they
the this far left group now what we're
calling their aggressive ultimately end
up strengthening a lot of ideas that
they should be against yeah what we're
seeing with Trump yeah I was a meeting
today at the Guardian which is where I
work and I love the place and you know
he's his Britain's leading Lessing
newspaper and people in the audience
their first question is about Donald
Trump you know their first questions
were you know and you could see I'm
perhaps I'm reading too much into into
the audience members discuss what Donald
Trump was stopping her she taking on
reactionaries in you know or on his own
isn't besides so you know you've got
it's very hard to to get the notion that
there are two extreme rights there is
the wisest rewrite and I wouldn't until
a few weeks ago said Donald Trump was
only him you seem to be having that
right now yeah
there is the religious extreme right
business extreme right and you need to
fight them both for the same reasons and
with the same arguments it sees very
different people seem to find that very
very difficult to do it strikes me is
the only principled position but I am
actually I walked onto any campus in
America and said there shall be no
platform not only would there be no
platform but they'd be trigger warned
you they go into a safe space all the
other stuff we're talking about and then
you know a frightening day yeah right
I've had several guests that I didn't
think we're that frightening that for
some reason have to have trigger
warnings issued before they they speak
on campuses so look a lot of this is
happening in Europe first which is
another reason that I'm talking about it
so much because I don't want it
you take hold here the way it has taken
hold in Europe what do you make of the
far-right parties that are now winning
across Europe right marine lepen just
one in France weird I now see that in
Denmark and Sweden far-right parties are
leading in polls for the first time ever
Belgium so this thing seems to be much
metastasizing right in front of our eyes
yeah I mean I mean the European Union
it's not like the USA
you know it's trying to be like the USA
without the common culture and the
common institutions and as I'm fond of
pointing out to people who knew you want
to be like the US I said well the USA
had one hell of a civil war before it
became in the USA for today anyway do
you want do you want them there are
other reasons but there's two things I
want to say one you might quite like the
other mega recipe might quite like is is
I we seem to agree on this is this you
can't run around shrieking your head off
yeah having trigger warnings and safe
spaces when I'd know celebrity or a
politician make society off-color remark
about homosexuals or women looks like
sets this mark about women and have it
leading the news and calmness on noon of
times need including a cold shower to
calm themselves down afterwards and then
and then ignore religious homophobia
including you just don't do that without
paying a price because don't think
people aren't watching you you know
don't think the rest of society lots of
political rising on the left as well as
the right it's like it's a private club
you know they talk to themselves but
yeah the right walks is Fox News less
walks is Jon Stewart's you know they
just talk themselves it's like a private
club and everyone understands the rules
and they forget this outside as a walk
you get outsiders are saying you bloody
hypocrite yeah you know you you will you
will have one rule for white people and
and
the rest and you will not stand up to
get back so there is that that doesn't
matter
political correctness in Britain has
become has become this kind of swear
words and it doesn't mean stuff that you
would understand Bible it directs it
means deep deep deep hypocrisy miss
governmental government so that's all
through you can blame left that on the
other hands you know beautiful but swear
on your progress let's go you're great
engraving the pen we will shine we will
not you know we will not give up on you
with your fellow citizens when it comes
to point where you'd you sell tell with
you you know you are opponents the
difficulty is that is this come identity
American viewers know about this we've
now got the worst type of of leftist
leading our opposition party later party
whose right a caricature if I had to
write an example of what the worst of
the left is in Britain Jeremy Corbyn go
Michael Jeremy the only good thing about
them becoming Labour leader is books on
roads are now selling my selfish point
of view of science yeah you know is is
you've got the terrible right in America
I was trumped in France with National
Front in Sweden and Denmark and all
these places Poland and Hungary popping
up all over Europe not just because in
the great part because the European Tim
currency has been one of the great
economic mistakes and then you've got a
left in a space where a principle flesh
would be certainly in Britain you've got
this kind of yoga figure that will go
along with any organization however
fascistic
as long as it's an t wet so you know
lots of people are feeling a bit
political politically homeless yeah does
it all feel like a perfect storm to you
what's going on right now and again this
this is the stuff that's after your book
when we talk about the refugees and some
of the economic problems
in Europe and this you know dealing with
radical Islam it was going on while you
were writing the book obviously but it
seems it seems to me we have like five
things right now that are all working at
the same time then you toss in social
media you toss in you know that we see
videos from everywhere now we see we can
see the headings we can see bombing you
know so you can see you can see
religious violence and you can see state
violence all the time that we really
have all of this happening at once and
it's leading to a to a very strange
place yeah I mean I think one thing Dave
we can say with certainty that whoever
it was Francis Fukuyama who said off the
falls and full of Berlin walls at the
end of history
history's over boring without stupid
essay and and you can't you can't let me
get back to the point I made you right
to the start that the weirdness and the
hypocrisy and the awful betrayal of
people you get on people who call
themselves a left comes where they don't
have a socialist alternative you they
don't have the Soviet Union Falls
socialism collapses across the world no
one believes it anymore and that was
fine for a while if I may generalize in
a very glib way that was fine for a
while because capitalism we'll call it
what you will seems to be a great
success story mm-hmm seemed to work
that's why Frank Francis Fukuyama was
not such an idiot when he said history
was over well ever since the crash of
2008 that system of liberal capitalism
has failed and that's why you've got
this feeling of you know perfect storm
too many things coming at us at once is
it is not entirely you there's a
wonderful phrase by the Italian
socialist Antonio Gramsci the oldest bad
the new cannot be born in that
interregnum many strange strange forms
will appear it seems like that we don't
know what comes next we're not sure of
what we've got we're not sure it works
anymore not so it works oh yeah opening
this middle-class Americans watching
your program oh yeah their pay isn't
going up the super-rich we're getting
richer the American Dream doesn't seem
to quite work anymore even with it with
a
listen not quite clear where the
alternatives for that are so you get
these strains of Oren's free kiss forms
which when I wrote that for ya as I said
people just kept saying for your Nick
Nick Nick that's just those are guests
on the fringes well now it's on the main
screen going to that point what about
some of the tactics these guys use and I
want to talk a little bit about Chomsky
but first we can talk just sort of in
the more broader sense when I've seen
the way these guys debate the way they
treat topics and you know again
everyone's racist and all that they
don't seem to mind if they get caught in
lies they don't they love just throwing
out the bomb and then we let it spreads
like wildfire on social media and you
know there's that famous saying you know
it takes one second to lie but it takes
you know a lifetime to get it back or
whenever and it seems that a series of
these guys they love this and I don't
know look again I'm not on the right so
I can't write I don't like the right
I've never been part of the right so I
police them differently but I don't want
to see this from my guys so what do you
think about just the tactics sure easy
it doesn't behave any better than that
no me people look they don't look I'm
look I'm dealing in America with Trump
right this second with over-the-top bomb
Basset II so and again this is why look
I'm a guilty liberal in that sense that
sometimes I feel bad I spent so much
time on the guys on my side and that I'm
afraid you know people ask me all the
time am i afraid that ultimately this
will strengthen the right but I but to
me it's like if we don't stand up now
well then the game is over we just hand
it to the right which is what's
happening I think with Trump yeah well
there is a long tradition of you know if
you go back to to Stalin you know he got
gullible people to believe in so trials
where people confess the croc impossible
crimes that weren't committed so there
is that um I mean I'm less I'm less
interested I'm less concerned about left
and right than this
here's something that happens
with new media you now have States
Fox News I think it's a pretty bad thing
I think it's main audience seems to be
little girl this book is reasonable to
write but yeah it's a bad day you've got
nothing to do you got no ideas I know
I'll turn on Fox News it's you've now
got States Russia and Iran most notably
producing propaganda channels that are
dedicated pushing half-truths conspiracy
theories lies you know a jet shot down
over Ukraine
there's television channels in English
who are pumping stuff out so where else
wants if you're on the left in America
you just have to go on all about
something Nixon was putting out or
something in the Wall Street Journal
even something on Fox News and if you're
on the right in America you can play
about New York Times you know
deliberately covering something up
now you suddenly got whole states with
their secret services their foreign
offices their propaganda arms behind
them pumping material into the West
which is instantly taken up by both the
far left and the far right he's it's
very difficult to ascertain in Britain
so as I say things have gone much much
tougher than they have in America it's
very very difficult to tell them apart
the people who support Putin for
instance and Russia today you know
you've got marine lepen doing it who is
the lead for French far-right party you
got yours Galloway who's his strange
combination there the less business the
mist in Britain
you look at me and say you've got a kind
of merger of the extremes against
liberal democracy and they both equally
kill Hooton they're both equally
sympathetic to Iran they what matters
for the most is is building
conspiratorial narrative so in a lot of
ways we really could blame sort of
mainstream media for this craziness
right because it seems to me that for a
long time mainstream media which had no
competition before the digital
they did such a poor job that then they
handed everything over to the digital
side and I think for a while the online
media for the first few years of it I
think they did do a really nice job in
breaking stories and getting out
information yeah you wouldn't you
wouldn't get otherwise and now it seems
like the gloves are off and now it's
anything's true
nobody knows who to trust yeah except
some kind of binary division between new
media and old video it's good it's a
prom date if you are me at the Guardian
observer or on the LA time to you you do
reports on the LA Times you've done a
terrible job of your allowing all these
cranks these fruitcakes these flim-flam
merchants from all over the world to
walk all over you the man or woman the
LA Times has looked at our business
models collapse you know we're trying to
start bureaus in in Peking in Beijing
you you know give me a break you know we
can bet we can bet we can barely get a
reporter up you up the road San
Francisco the business models for if you
like serious be serious for us
journalism is getting hard on half
sustain although I'm sure the LA Times
and newspapers and across America to my
knowledge having met many men we work on
are really dedicated to try and keep it
going but yeah Indian the lack of money
talks you know money talks but the
silence that comes from the lack of
money is a silence which guess which
just closes debate so the gap is just
being filmed and what worries me is is
not people talking rubbish
or people talking people they always
have is where are you going to get the
reliable reports on what is happening
and peaking well Beijing where are you
going to get the reliable pork reports
on how Putin is manipulating European
opinion that's getting hard and Hobbs
- okay well as it as someone that I
consider an expert in this space
you decide who to trust I I really don't
know anymore I you know I follow a lot
of different organizations right left
middle you know as reputable and some
off the deep end and I try to pilfer out
some knowledge and and some truth and I
try not to only follow things that
reinforce my beliefs which is another
huge problem in social media has given
us but how do you decide who to trust
accused of being horribly old-fashioned
supper I mean there are civil
organization so I trust you know I still
trust not stole New York Times news
pages yeah unless it's because I know
there's a very very strong editing
process there and this opinion pages are
set for us and what have you don't know
that may change as the business model
journalist and goes down but I still
look they had an op-ed on the front page
for the first time in 95 years just now
that's right how disgraceful let's go
around this wheels go round have a demo
sorry we don't want your bloody opinions
we also say give us some news